he is the freshly minted World Series
MVP the Astros centerfielder George
Springer joining us on the program
George you come down from that game
seven high I don't think so but not yet
has been a wild few days and and just a
long 50 days but it it's been great take
us back to before game seven I was told
that you're the one that kind of got the
team up and going and and you know
trying to take the tension out of the
air prior to Game seven tell the
audience what you did to get your
teammates to relax or have fun a little
bit more yeah you know I just I got to
the field and and I thought to myself
you know how many times do you can
actually say as a player that I got to
play one in the World Series and now to
this is everything that we ever dreamed
of so we might as well have fun and
enjoy it so I went over time under the
speaker and I put on my my old-school
80s took playlists you know that it's
got some Gap Band on it pulling the gang
and it's a different vibe and you know
it's just kind of cool that the guys
have some fun it's it's not your
stereotype of go obviously pump up stuff
is you know a good five good songs and I
just try to have some fun some people in
there and I think it worked what is it
like to go to the plate you know with
the game on the line in game seven and
we look at it and feel like there's got
to be so much pressure but when you're
there in the batter's box and you know
you've got to make something happen what
is that feeling like you know it's an
interesting one because in game game to
game five game you know basically game
two through seven I just felt as this
all I had to do is get the first base
but now the first game it was was was
when I felt that and that's not a good
feeling because you try to do too much
you try to do things that
wouldn't don't homily do and and you
don't even I don't know why you're just
doing it but when it came to Game seven
it was you know what I got to get
something to hit and if and if he throws
it I can't miss it so it it actually a
major focus and and and and slow down a
lot more what was the scouting report on
Clayton Kershaw I'm the right guy to ask
that question okay but others did so
there must have been a game plan there
yeah
a few guys on our team so were able to
figure him out you know he's a guy that
is if you can get him up I think that
you know it was what we were trying to
get him up in his own because his slider
is this slider is so good and it's and
it has such good downward playing on it
you know I can now see why guys you know
swinging added a lot so we had to get
him up in the strike zone especially you
know hopefully if he could hang a slider
but he's so tough you know et you know
the the colas was was honestly just get
him up in the strike zone and let's hope
he makes a mistake he's George Springer
the World Series MVP joining us Dan
Patrick show where is that MVP right now
George it is sitting in my living room
I'm on the coffee table it's a good
conversation I know I'm not gonna break
it on the coffee table
it's a conversation piece that's a
conversation starter George if somebody
comes in my some of my family here and
it made they've they've picked it up
it's it's heavy
yeah well you know the other ones heavy
food I've been holding it around for the
last five days what does it mean to be
the MVP of the World Series
it's
it's great you know it's it's it's
obviously an honor you know there's
there's there's only one of these a year
and you know as as long as anybody ever
speaks about the world you know
oh there's in 2017 you know I guess I'll
always be the MVP for Nestle I guess you
can't ever take it away from me but it's
it's not about me kind of you know I
don't I don't could could care less
about an individual you know stat knives
they didn't didn't perform well and and
the AAAS and and and and the team won
and and the most important part is now
is the team won and and you know Houston
has a championship what did you think
when you saw that 2014 Sports
Illustrated cover with Astros winning it
all in three years did you did you
believe that the Astros could win it all
in three years I believe that we could
you know I I'm not ever gonna put a
timetable on it cuz this game is it's
crazy it's it's hard and you know you
never know what could happen but I
remember having a lot of conversations
with some guys who are in that Clubhouse
now who you know all we talked about was
if we stay the course and we just keep
getting better every year and we keep
improving you never know and you know I
I don't everything we thought it was you
know gonna happen but as as as the years
start to fold out and our team started
to play the way our team was you know a
lot of guys did you know what I think
you can do it and and then it obviously
happened what did you get Justin
Verlander for wedding gift or have you
got name something I don't really know
if there's anything I can honestly get
that guy that he doesn't already have no
I haven't gotten him anything yet I
probably probably will I'm I'm gonna
have to probably send it to him I don't
know what part of the world he's in
right now you know he got married in
Italy so I don't know if he's
honeymooning
in Italy but you can always until he
comes back for spring training there
George yeah I'm gonna have to wait till
spring training and I'm just gonna drop
it off at his locker and you know hope
he doesn't already have it and you know
now Korea gets in gay I mean this is
putting a lot of pressure on everybody
else on the team there George
yeah there's you know there's only a few
more guys who have to tie the knot here
so did you know that Korea was going to
get engaged yeah he had told he had told
a few of us we were kind of like what's
your you know I hope you have a plan B
and he said he didn't have a plan B you
know I was like well you know I guess
that sucks for users my plan aid didn't
involved a baseball game so it was like
I either had a plan a and that was it
and I was gonna hope that she said yes
and he he he admitted he didn't have a
plan B so wait wait you just got like
regular engagement yours wasn't anything
special I mean it was it was it was it
was it was it was special for us of
course course it was an it was in a much
different setting
what's a different place it was on a
beach but you know for fur for him he
said he was gonna do it if we won I
thought he was crazy I didn't think he
was gonna do it but he did it and he he
can admit he didn't have a plan B and if
we didn't win he'd probably still be
trying to figure it out it's pretty good
hey it was a great story it was fun
watching and hitting five bombs in the
World Series that's pretty impressive
it's a short list of those who have done
it but George enjoy the offseason and
congratulations appreciate it thank you
very much no that's George Springer for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]